so good morning everyone thank you for
coming I'm very happy to be here I think
I have some being invited because that
we have some challenges that we are
interested in finding help with and we
like to get you involved in our science
as Dan said I'm working for Brookhaven
National Laboratory most of you will
probably not never have heard of the
National Labs the Department of Energy
operates 17 laboratories within the US
and they are responsible next to the
universities for fundamental research in
energy sciences which spans quite a
quite a long way it goes from Batteries
new materials to biology and plants and
things like that each of those labs will
operate large-scale experimental
facilities and also computational
facilities they are that's what sort of
distinguishes us from universities we
have much larger okay thank you good
otherwise I'll have to talk more
directly into the microphone so our
remit is to do fundamental research and
we take it sort of two things to the
prototype stage and then we would hand
it off to to industry our key challenge
is as I said experimental fact we have
experimental facilities and with all
technologies as you see today
experimental facilities also become much
more data intensive and I'll be talking
about this in detail one of the key
challenges for us is that the the data
rate is growing exponentially and with
the experiments we are going from we're
having a paradigm shift in the past we
would collect data people would take at
home it's sort of in the megabyte to 2
gigabyte range they take it home and
analyze it what we have today is that we
we have data streams and the gigabytes
terrible
a second range and people can take it
home and they want to do real-time
steering of experiments now where's the
challenge aid there's data challenge
generally but most of our scientists are
used to ride their software in Python
and at small-scale what we now need is
tools to enable them to still use Python
wherever possible but do it at scale and
so this is where we're looking to this
community for solutions to say well how
can we do this how can we enable
scientists that are not necessarily
extremely computer savvy to use the same
tools as before but produce much more
scalable solutions and now I'm gonna
talk about what so some of our
challenges look like as I said the
National Laboratories operate a whole
range of facilities in 27 and total six
of those are actually a pro operated at
Brookhaven National Lab which is the
largest number of all of them and they
span a whole range of different things
so there there's a relativistic heavy
ion collider if you don't take anything
back from that it's nuclear physics
we're looking at the start of the
universe what materials look like at
that time within that experiment we have
the National synchrotron light source
this is the newest and brightest a
synchrotron in the world it's a tool
that enables you to probe materials and
observe physical chemical and biological
processes as they are happening you're
making films of things that are they're
evolving we have to Center for
functional nanomaterials where we are
looking at materials in detail how they
are building up how you grow your your
materials how you build them how folds
might develop or not hopefully we have
an accelerator test facility
accelerators is something that we use
for many of our experiments most of you
will have heard of the Large Hadron
Collider and CERN we are obviously not
operating that particular experiment
but we're doing the computing or a large
part of the computing for that
experiment at Brookhaven National Lab
we're actually the largest data center
outside of CERN within that
collaboration we're also involved in
atmospheric radiation measurement this
is not really radiation this is
measuring the sky the atmosphere looking
how that's developing in support of
climate research in addition to those
national user facilities we also
involved in two more activities the
Belcher experiment which is an neutrino
experiment at CERN it's about a quarter
of the size of the the Large Hadron
Collider but again very large large data
volumes and then quantum chromodynamics
which is a theory program that supports
nuclear physics and they have need large
computing facilities so what you can see
from all of those is that the science
that we do is data driven and so that
the computer science that we do at
Brookhaven National Lab is all focused
at supporting these kind of experiments
to develop the tools the fundamental
principles that we can do the analysis
in the form that they needed at the at
the scale that they needed what does
that mean so in 2017 we reached a
milestone we are currently archiving
hundred just over 100 petabytes of data
that makes us the second largest
scientific data archive in the US and
the fourth largest worldwide behind the
ECMWF the UK Met Office and NOAA we
store a lot of data we process even more
so in 2016 we processed 400 petabytes of
data this year we expect to reach 500
petabytes that gives you sort of a
little scale on some of our experiments
that we're looking at so they they go
from a single experiment might produce
10 to 20 terabytes of data to 10
petabytes for a single experiment that
runs a few days
so that sort of the rough scale that
we're working with a lot of the data is
processed and kept on site others
shipped out and and to others we take in
and give out about forty petabytes a
year that we ship across the world we
have some software that allows us to
process not just data on side but also
off side which is called panda and in
2016 panda enable to the analysis of by
one point six exabyte of data that's
just for one of our experiments just
sort of as a background so where do we
need and why do we need real-time
analysis and decision-making
well we new to neat streaming
decision-making or support basically
when data arrives at the velocity and
high velocity and volume basically at a
velocity and volume that a human can't
look at it any longer and make
meaningful decisions the second thing is
that critical decisions have to be taken
if the data just comes and I don't
really care about it you can still
collect it and do it afterwards but in
this case we don't one of the key things
that we have in science is that the
events of interest are rare it's we're
not interested in things that you've
seen before that happens all the time
they're nice we collect them statistics
great but what we're interested in are
the things that are unusual that are
rare well you think why is this just a
flaw in my experiment or is this
something new is it a new discovery and
at that point I really want to go deep
and I want to be able to say no this
isn't a flaw this is something really
cool and new and I want to establish as
many facts as possible and it takes as
with many things that require intuition
and discovery it takes a lot of tacit
knowledge in the the user of the
experiments to interpret it at the point
in time you want to give it them as much
help as possible but you really require
their input at that moment in time it's
a very personal thing
so what does streaming analysis include
and in in terms of experimental control
so we analyzed the facts of the
situation
what what's really happening and what we
want to see is not oh this just happened
we want to see we think this is going to
happen so we want to catch any phenomena
as it's evolving so that we can go
deeper and that's that sort of the
clicky thing it's a rare event we want
to catch it as early as possible because
when it's over we can't do anything any
longer we can't go back in an experiment
we also need to consider background
information this is the thing where I
say well is this something new or have I
seen it a thousand time and therefore
yeah I can let it go okay and we want to
be able to request more information at
that moment in time if I think it's
something interesting and I want to be
able to consider alternatives so if you
have a complex biological system there
might be many things going on at the
same time the question is which one do I
want to focus on I might not be able to
capture all of them and if I focus in
this area I might not see something else
so I have to look at what are my
alternatives what do what do i might
miss so that I can make a decision and
then I basically have to set priorities
and and changed my experiment to visit
physically as I'm going on so this is
sort of the background to this so our
first example is one of the smaller
scale ones this is a transmission
electron microscope I'm not going to
expect that any of you know what it is
but it basically is a tool that allows
us to probe materials you have very thin
slices and you can look at the materials
you can interact it interacts with a
specimen the specimen changes one of the
challenges with this technique is that
it's damaging it's very good to figure
out the structure but it damages
your material as you're investigating it
so you have to be quick to get to the
point that you want but it might take a
while for your reaction to happen to
capture that so you have to have a fine
fine balance between taking sort of
snapshots where you radiate thee to some
extent that the material and damage it
to the point where something is really
happening and then you really want to to
get all the images that you you get want
to have in great detail so that's sort
of the challenge here it's a growing
method there's about 500 of those
instruments worldwide twenty to thirty
of those and national laboratories and
like everything else the technology is
rapidly evolving we were not very many
years back you would capture something
like maybe 100 images an hour so so you
really have the time you collect an
image you can look at it and say oh that
looks nice or not and now we we have new
newer tools or instruments like like the
one at Brookhaven that collects 400
images a second so even if I could show
this to you there's absolutely no way
you could see anything another challenge
that we had so I'll show some of the the
type of data that you get so the
preferred method to analyze this data in
detail was called a postdoc who would
sit there and look at it and say that
looks interesting and no that's not
right and yes this is the sort of the
statistics behind it clearly at 400
images a second we can't hire enough
postdocs but to do that work nor would
they want to do it because it's really
boring so we obviously need
computational approaches for it so here
the challenge is 400 images a second
that's about 3 gigabits gigabytes a
second and and data volume and you want
to do real-time analysis on it so that
you can steer the experiment so the
what you see there is sort of the type
of data that you get those particles
that are moving in the material as you
can see it's it's quite quite a noisy
background this is actually a relatively
clear example to be honest and with this
so you want to identify the particles
you want to see how they evolve some of
them will be merging some of them will
be going apart again and you want to get
statistics on how big they are so for
that we developed a convolutional neural
network based approach to analyze those
images and filter out what's what's in
it this is sort of the second picture so
you can see that here on the on the
right the image which where we've
basically identified the the the
particles and we at the same time we are
collecting the size and the statistics
of the sizes and the size distribution
so this is one of those types of
analysis there's many different
experiments that you can do with this
but this is one of the key type of
experiments that are done with it
this now allows the scientists to see as
a collect those statistics as it's going
on the next step is then to identify
areas of interest within this where they
might want to go deeper where they have
where you highlight that as it's going
on there's a sort of the next step that
we're looking for
it's wonderful so another type of
electron microscope is is a cryo e/m
this is one of the things that we are
looking forward to that gets even more
difficult as you can see this is for
biological experiments in particular
it's used also in healthcare so anything
on on the biological side Cancer
Research they are particularly keen on
that it's mainly for biological samples
as you can see the contrast is abysmal
you get the same data rates as before
but you as you can see it basically you
can't see it's very difficult and you
still want to do the same kind of
detection mechanisms on it and so we're
looking for four methods for that and
we've we've used the same algorithm as
before with some improvements could
retrain it and so that that was a very
nice success still identify not maybe
everything but but a large part of the
proteins that are in the sample and and
here's some some examples of the
different types of networks and
algorithms that we used different types
of training so this is one of the
challenges with any kind of machine
learning algorithm the training is that
the training data is really really
important you can see this here the
performance of those algorithms really
varies and one of the research areas I'm
not going to talk in too much detail
here but one of our research areas is to
develop more robust machine learning
algorithms that are not so dependent in
their quality of output on the training
data so that we can enable more
scientists or users generally that that
have less experience in a to to produce
results that that are they can rely on
so the second example that I want to
talk about is our synchrotron light
source I mentioned that before I brought
up a couple of picture here just to give
you some some background on what that
looks like so synchrotrons have gone
through through different phases but the
the current generation looked like a
doughnut as you can see that there's a
few around the world but not too many
it's basically a ring which accelerates
protons or electrons and then you have
sort of what we call beam lines going
off and at the end of each of them is
what-what basically an instrument to to
investigate materials of various kinds
and different sizes a synchrotron like
this one in full build-out will have 60
different beam lines each beam line can
be configured in different ways so say
factor of 2 basically that makes 120
different instruments which produce
different types of data need different
kinds of treatment an experiment lasts
maybe eight hours something like that
sometimes longer each experiment will be
different a different community can be
material scientists that can't next time
it will be a biologist and then you have
someone who looks at catalysis or
anything else care chemicals so in
designing those on Alice's algorithms
you have to be very very careful on the
other hand we also have to scale we
can't develop a different analysis
algorithm for every user so what we're
looking for our building blocks that
work for for many of them and then we
customize it to a specific scientific
area and for example machine learning
works very well in this area but but
other techniques work too but this is
sort of the the kind of challenges that
that we have what you also see here is
sort of the the scale change that we
have so this light source we also had a
this generation on site which is
actually my new home we've converted
that into to our computing Center the
old light source but this new one is a
thousand ten thousand times brighter
than the old one
brightness usually goes with data rate
that sort of gives you a feeling so you
have users who are really used to two
megabytes of data going to terabytes a
second and that's a huge huge challenge
I want to focus in my examples on two
particular beam lines because they they
sort of want one is sort of our training
beam line because they have it has a
smaller data data rate with four four
and a half gigabytes a second so we can
train a lot of our tools on it but the
one that we are really aiming to to work
which is challenging us is the the hxn
beam line which will have 50 gigabytes a
second sustained data rate and will
produce one to five terabytes a second
and burst and that's all interesting
just from a pure hardware perspective to
get this off the instrument and then
from from a processing perspective one
of the things that I would also like to
mention because in the past we've
actually done quite a lot of work also
with commercial frameworks for stream
processing one of the challenges we've
found is that the data that we have is
highly correlated so those are not
independent events so if you have many
of the frameworks like I'm like Kafka
for example it's purely based their
performance is based on independence of
events if you try to actually bring
order into that and correlate events the
performance collapses at this point so
it's a very different challenge in that
that aspect because I as I said what we
want to do so what we want to do is to
to identify emerging phenomena so the
ordering of your events
and the the relationship to each other
is quite important in the analysis what
we want to do on those beamlines
is observing and controlling physical
chemical and biological processes that
means that we work on very short
timescales that we have to process this
data and give feedback so that it's
still meaningful that occur that the
user can still react to it and what we
do is so in sit you which means
something happens but we also do larger
scale experiments in our Parranda what
we can do is take whole things like
batteries for example in observe them as
they're working and looking at how
everything is happening inside them how
the chemical processes are working how
they can be improved how they can be
steered so that's that's highly exciting
microchips is another one so we've
worked for a very long time for example
with IBM and other companies who come to
the neck to the synchrotron and test
their latest and greatest equipment and
materials with us to see if they perform
in the way that they expect so what have
we done so far one of the things is that
experiments are not perfect which is
you've seen there already from the
previous image that we what we create is
often quite noisy because we're sort of
at the really at the edge of what you
can detect and then in addition to that
we have art get artifacts in our images
that we don't want to have and that
don't help us in in the in the analysis
afterwards so we've developed methods
that help us to heal images and what we
do there is a sort of take classical
machine learning but we integrate that
with with key physical knowledge so that
we can can heal and fill it this in with
a knowledge of what should should be
there and so you can see some of those
healed images here we do that in the
streaming fashion and that then goes
into the analysis pipeline after that we
then again use machine learning deep
learning approach to identify different
artifacts in in the images and what
we've done here is is really to look at
the key artifacts that we want would
want to see or what would be interested
in seeing or expecting to see that takes
the physical knowledge of the
experiments but it doesn't offer the
experimental set up but not necessarily
of the material that you are
investigating that sort of the next step
then to say so I've seen this what does
this mean for the experiment so this is
finding out what's the meaning starting
with an interpretation for that you have
to again bring the physical or
biological knowledge in to help with
that interpretation as I said so we're
producing data at very very high rates
even if I can do the interpretation that
I've just showed it still doesn't mean I
have something that I can show to a user
that they can actually use to make a
decision as I said if I show you four
hundred images a second
or more this is this is actually more
this goes into the thousands of images a
second you can't make a decision I have
to guide guide the user to a point where
they can say here's something important
and that's that's what we use for that
is visual analytics which really uses
guidance from the user to say what's
important to me in this particular
experiment plus some background
information on what people usually tend
to find interesting to prioritize that
and show that to the user highlighted in
different ways and forms and showing the
data in different ways
that they can zoom in themselves and say
well this looks interesting or this is
different from what I expected and so we
have quite a number of interfaces for
that that help the user to explore that
looking at different ways of how we can
can show this kind of of
multi-dimensional data in a new way that
enables that interaction and then the
decision making what I have now is just
a few examples of things that we've done
on other experiments but that sort of
that go in the same same direction this
is a recent publication and where we
basically worked used machine learning
to interpret the structure of
nanoparticles from the experiment that
was never done before this usually work
that takes months you get get some
images out you then have to decide for
them and see what what it actually means
with a new with a machine learning
approach we'll were able to interpret
them as the data is collected giving the
user much more input and to help them to
interpret and steer their experiment
another thing that we've done this is
also a Python based approach so for many
of the things that we look at we don't
just look at one experiment but you need
computational studies you need different
types of experiments to really explore a
material and all its properties that it
has not just to structure the properties
properties under different conditions so
when you then come to interpreted the
quote the problem is that all the data
is quite quite different and so you have
to create an environment where it makes
that makes it easy for people to
integrate the data and pull out the key
results and information out of the
different experiments and put them into
one place so that they can interpret it
and learn what they need to our
computational modeling infrastructure
does that
in the past this used to be what we call
hero efforts because it takes a long
long time to get all of this done and
everyone had a one-off approach this
year is a automated approach that makes
it easy to take it's the results from
different experiments and integrate them
the software is is freely available and
is heavily in use and has been used on
many many different studies and this
just highlights a recent paper in Nature
communications for example for some
discovery that was enabled with that
kind of tool that couldn't have been
done otherwise this one I've just
brought up to again reinforce what I
said at the start we have tools today
that that worked for similar methods on
the old synchrotron and and they work
fine on that those data rates the
challenge is how do we take those Python
codes and bring them to the scale that
that we need and so we've done quite a
bit of work and in studying different
Python frameworks to see how we compare
paralyze the code what do we need to
change maybe in the background what are
the trade-offs between different
approaches and so that thought has been
very very interesting we haven't found
so far quite the approach that we like
that gets us to the scale that we would
want so we're looking for for input from
anyone who has ideas to push this quite
a bit further than than where we are
today but we were very open and where we
would be happy to collaborate with
anyone who has ideas and we have
challenges for you if you have tools and
solutions so and then I just wanted to
close off with talking a little bit
about who we are so Dan mentioned I'm
leading the computational science
initiative that is basically all
research computing computer science
research applied math researches is
directed by me at the
Tory what we've done is to pull experts
from many different departments together
in in under one umbrella we reach out a
lot to the domain scientists as you've
seen for some of their approaches it's
not just the computer science that can
solve it but we we need the domain
knowledge and integrate that into our
solutions as well just to solve our
questions and so this this broad
approach is really important to us and
we we obviously we do we're more on the
research side so we also work with all
the scientists that do the operational
side and the actual deployment of the
tools very closely together and to
develop new new approaches for for our
our challenges the computational designs
initiative has now five departments
Barbara Chapman is a leads our computer
science and mathematics division she's a
leading researcher in programming models
and compilers so she leads a whole area
that that is not just focused on the
algorithms but anything that goes with
it to make your algorithm faster if you
you're attacking challenges like we do
it's not just the algorithm it's the
underlying computer computer software
the system software compiler directives
networking Hardware all of that so all
this is under directed by her Eric Lance
all leads our scientific data and
computing center so this is the hundred
petabyte archive plus a lot of computing
going on of course and as it's a data
intensive lab we we have quite a varied
combination of systems we have high
throughput computing but we also have
high performance computing and various
forms they're specialized obviously for
data intensive applications then we have
Shantanu jar he leads the Center for
data-driven discovery
Shantanu is a joint appointment with
Rutgers University
and he the Center for data-driven
discovery is sort of our outreach arm
where we apply the tools that we've
developed in two different domain
science areas and so he he's on that
side nicht imperio is the computational
science laboratory leader this is more
on the classic numerical simulation side
optimizing those kind of courses those
kind of codes and he is he and his team
also give a lot of courses so we will be
organizing another hackathon for a
specific platform from Intel in the
summer for example those kind of things
and then one of our newest activities is
computing for national security as you
can imagine many of these techniques in
particular when it comes to high
throughput in real time analysis
computing can be used in many different
areas not just an open science and so we
will be much more aggressively pushing
into that field because we think we have
something to offer there and I wanted to
leave you sort of with the key research
initiatives that that we are focused on
those those are the things that drive us
and from what you've heard me talk about
you can see probably where they are
coming from real-time analysis an
ultra-high throughput data streams well
that you've seen that that's clearly one
of our core focus areas and everything
that that is needed for that one of the
things on this list that I wanted to
mention which is pretty cool I think is
our one of our newer project analysis on
the wire what we've basically said there
is much more data and transfer than
there is in storage so could we do
something with the data while it's being
moved rather than waiting for it to
arrive and can we develop a framework
that allows us to play place selected
analysis on the network and apply it to
selected data sets so it so that's what
we're doing there a second area is
autonomous optimal experimental design
so if you think of these experiments
that
we do we usually explore a design space
I'm looking for a new material that I
will to solve a particular problem no we
can't go in and say well this is exactly
what I want so we have to try it out the
question is how can you design those
experiments and the pathway through the
experiments and their analysis to
optimize this so that we don't have to
do too many experiments and get quicker
to the solution as a background for
example to develop a new material for
the aerospace industry takes 20 to 30
years from from the initial discovery to
actually having a new material that's
used by the industry what they would
like to do is bring this down to five
years now without computational tools
better experiments better analysis of
the data faster analysis that wouldn't
be possible and so those are the kind of
challenges that we're thinking about and
then the last one as I mentioned the
experiments that we have produce vast
amounts of data I talked about the
microchip experiment where we think that
will produce about 1 to 10 petabytes for
four for one experiment that you need to
analyze we've talked to two researchers
of the brain initiative for example
where they said well if I I could today
image a mouse brain completely that
would produce 60 petabytes of data
I can't possibly unalike that so the
question is often obviously they would
want to do more than one mouse brain to
get any statistical information out of
it so the question is for us how can we
enable the analysis of those kind of
datasets and you have to mat remember by
that that at the end of the day there's
a person there so our cognitive
abilities are limited in comparison to a
computer so how do I bring down what's
in there to a person an enabler to do
interactive analysis I don't want to
start something come back two years
later I want to be able to fly around
try out things how can I enabled
that will need new computer systems new
hardware new system software new
algorithms and so that's the kind of
thing that we are looking for and with
that I'm leaving and say thank you if
you have any questions yep it well it
depends on what kind of science you want
to do
really and so the I think the in many
universities are actually involved in
those experiments this we run the
facility but the users are of all those
facilities are largely in the
universities so what this is is
basically a bridge for you what we're
trying to do is to help University
scientists to to work with those
experiments and to analyze it if you're
in those fields you will have those data
challenges
okay well thank you very much
[Applause]